all right what's going on guys this is
rob and if you talk to anybody out there
who has been reading dc comics for well
really since the 90s and you asked them
what would you say the top five comic
book stories are from dc comics i
guarantee you somewhere in that list
will be kingdom come and rightfully so
kingdom come is one of the greatest
stories ever written by dc comics right
it's written by mark wade and it's drawn
by alex ross for those of you guys who
are curious about the artist alex ross
is kind of like the premier comic book
artist the definitive guy doesn't really
draw comics as much as he used to this
guy was where it was at and this story
is kind of like the definitive dc story
for a variety of reasons so the reason
we're covering this is one i'm gonna be
on a cruise for the next week and a half
or so and two because we're covering uh
dark crisis infinite frontier and this
is one of the worlds they landed on and
instead of just kind of giving you guys
some sort of ad hoc explanation i
figured we would actually remaster the
kingdom come series we did before and
bring it to you here so you can
basically see what this story is about
and why it's such a big deal they landed
here so the way the kingdom come opens
up is it's really kind of given to us by
a quote now while this story does deal
with like what is essentially a
superhero or superhuman civil war in dc
comics really more of like a civil war
event before marvel civil war it's also
just as much a religious story it's not
really on the nose or anything like that
like the god of abraham will save us but
it's one of those things where there's a
lot of religious underpinnings and kind
of like armageddon-esque scenarios and
and really just kind of an overall feel
that goes with it so what we get here is
we're told and there followed hail and
fire mingled with blood there fell a
great star from the heaven burning as if
it were a lamp and i beheld and heard an
angel saying with a loud voice woe woe
woe to the inhabiters of the earth and
what you end up getting here is this
kind of moment where you basically have
norman mckay who is reading from the
book of revelation to wesley dots now
this moment here is highly important and
it's really the most significant if you
understand the history of wesley dot so
in dc comics way back in the 1980s well
technically 1989 so really like the late
1980s with sandman volume 2 issue number
one we were introduced to a character
that you've all probably heard of called
dream of the endless and the way this
worked is that there came a point in
time where in the dc continuity itself
back in the 1930s dream of the endless
had basically been trapped on earth
right literally had his crystal taken
away from him and all kinds of stuff but
regardless he was stuck on earth and the
result was that it wreaked havoc across
the earth itself in the sense that if if
dream of the endless is captured people
can't dream properly their sleep doesn't
work the way it's supposed to so what
you had were all these people across the
world that were experiencing bouts of
insomnia or they were just sleeping
continually or they were having like
waking dreams or basically they were
awake but they weren't really there they
were just dreaming all the time wesley
dodds is one of those guys the big
difference here is that wesley dodds had
a lot of prophetic dreams so he was
essentially dreaming of the future
different things along those lines what
kingdom come does and what's so cool
about this is this story was written
back before you had the new 52 and what
that means is this takes place during
what was called new earth basically the
continuity that came after the events of
crisis on infinite earth so there's only
one universe here and the reason why
that matters is because when it came to
new earth in guys like wesley dodds
while he did technically get a new
origin a lot of it was pretty intact
with the way he existed way back before
the events of crisis on infinitives and
the way this story is told it really
kind of harkens back to the heroes of
yesteryear so while technically this is
post-crisis in a lot of ways it feels
like they're referencing the age of
superheroes from the golden age of
comics from the 1940s in dc's publishing
history it's one of the reasons why i
love it so much right because alex ross
art always remind me of an era or a time
when superheroes stood a little bit
taller and walked a little more
confidently and there was no ambiguity
determining the difference between the
good guys and the bad guys the good guys
fought the bad guys and the day was
saved and that was it there was no such
thing as anti-heroes or anything like
that the waters weren't murky but the
reality here is that wesley dodds even
growing into his old age had seemingly
never lost the power of dream of the
endless and so what that means is that
what he's experiencing right now are
these visions and he even tells norman
mckay seven thunders will utter their
voices and it was given unto him to make
war with the saints babylon falls norman
be the one who listens to me and this is
why it's important is because the way
this is presented to us is that wesley
dodds is considered to be a kook he's
considered to be a crazy person right
these visions of the end times and the
apocalypse coming and everything's going
to die and come to an end right all that
kind of stuff nobody really takes him
seriously and he can't convince anybody
that these dreams that he's having are
legitimate dreams and even in the old
sandman stories right the old wesley
dodd comics that in a lot of ways it was
kind of the question is this guy really
insane but you really saw dc sort of
toying with the idea that maybe he
really was crazy and so it was really
cool because in order to basically calm
him down right in order to calm him down
and to keep him or get him back to her
normal state he tells norman mckay you
have to read right you have to read from
the book now eventually wesley dodds
passes on and this is when norman mckay
basically gives us a kind of tour of
what the world looks like and we learned
things like the united nations has
enacted more meta-human censures and
there's a reason why meta-humans are
censured which basically means their
their ability to act publicly or speak
or what have you is curtailed not
necessarily in the sense that anything's
actually being done right these are
toothless measures that are happening
but what norman tells us here is he says
that he and wesley dodds and and his
wife you know norman's wife that they
were all friends at one point and wesley
would come over and they would talk and
different things along those lines but
he says before the bitterness overcame
him wesley and i would walk right we
would pick our way through the city for
hours he bemoaned the passing of things
like olympic games and nobel prizes
sometimes he'd ambush complete strangers
and ask them how much they missed of the
concept of human achievement and he says
i don't know what surprised me more the
oddity of the question or the growing
number of people who seemed to know what
he was talking about i tried to defuse
him i would joke that he was just some
old guy unable to appreciate this new
generation but he would never laugh that
wesley insisted that human initiative
began to erode the day people asked a
new breed to face their future for them
essentially the first time heroes began
to crop up and the first time humanity
looked at heroes to save them instead of
humanity saving themselves and he says
he mocked their worth these newcomers
and spoke instead of legends gone of
costume champions who had in his day
inspired human achievement not belittled
it he swore he'd never forget the world
they came from he wanted them to be
remembered and that's when you have
norman mckay who goes into planet
krypton which is obviously a play on
planet hollywood and when he's in there
it's basically this entire restaurant
modeled after the superheroes of
yesteryear green lantern wonder woman
aquaman the flash these different guys
batman superman and so on that the idea
of superheroes has become almost a kind
of thing that's a joke but it's almost a
a kind of commercialized concept that
instead of wonder woman standing for
righteousness and paving the way for
women to progress instead of superman
representing everything humanity can
become instead of batman representing
what it means to be a dick uh what you
have is all these different characters
who basically represent nonsense right
they represent commercialization and
they represent the loss of what it means
for society in terms of humans actually
being something that's worth the damn
and so what happens is he says the
sandman had gone to his grave without
one grain of faith in the future and the
saddest part was he was far from alone
with each passing day hope for tomorrow
has become more and more precious a
commodity among everyday folk still i
tried to keep the faith and hew to the
scriptures according to the word of god
the meek would someday inherit the earth
but god never accounted for the mighty
now this is where we get the reality of
how things had shifted now we'll find
out later on in terms of what had
actually taken place that it led to this
shift but what he says here is that the
world that wesley dodds had left behind
was not the world that he remembered you
know wesley dodds the sandman was from
the world of superman and wonder woman
and green lantern the flash these heroes
that represented everything humanity was
was striving to be that we as human
beings are fallible and and we usually
screw up more than we do things right
not because we're somehow incompetent or
inept we are in a lot of ways but only
because we as human beings don't learn
until we fail if we could somehow know
what the end result of our cons or of
our actions were going to be what those
consequences would be we would never
make mistakes but it's only by making
mistakes that we get better and we look
back on the consequences of those
choices that we truly begin to realize
what it is we lost or gained or anything
along those lines and then what had
happened here is somewhere along the
line the traditional superheroes of old
with dc comics superman flash and all
those guys they're out of the picture
and instead they're now replaced by all
these different heroes all these
different super-powered beings that
exist out there but what norman says is
i tell myself that this too shall pass
that humans still have a chance to
reclaim a world rightfully theirs while
it still exists this is the face of
superhuman might and superhuman odds
time has not yet run out for humanity
and so the reality here is that when it
comes to all these superpower beings out
there where initially they seem to rise
up and replace these various superheroes
that we're the most familiar with which
of course again we'll get back to them
but one you know as these these
characters rose up instead of them
becoming a new breed of superhero that
could basically help the world and make
it a better place that could somehow
lead them into a greener pasture instead
of doing that now these descendants of
superman and wonder woman and all these
guys right these next generation of
superheroes even if they're not the
biological children of superman and all
those different guys that now they just
fight for the sake of fighting right
they just plays off against each other
for the sake of facing off against each
other there's no wrong or reason here
there's no greater cause being served by
all this it's just people fighting for
the sake of fighting and there's a lot
of innocent people who get caught in the
collateral damage now one of the things
that we'll find over the course of
kingdom come is that humanity actually
brought it on itself that this whole
situation that you're seeing here is a
perfect example of be careful what you
ask for you just might get it because
humanity did this to itself and again
that's kind of the nature of what mark
wade says here is that we as people
don't learn our lessons until we screw
up but amidst all this fighting that's
taking place here suddenly in times
square there's a journalist that comes
on from the daily planet you may be
wondering why it's not lois lane you'll
find out
but basically she says like a
catastrophic event has happened in
kansas and so before we find out what
that is we actually end up following
norah mckay once he returns to his
church and the reality here is the role
he plays as as the head of the church
right with his congregation is to
instill hope in people whose hope is
barely hanging on by a threat right
wrong or otherwise regardless of how you
see religion in a lot of ways it really
is just a concept of hope that's really
all it is a construct for hope how much
faith people put in what they're hearing
and how much conviction they tie to what
they believe it really just shifts from
one person to the next but religion as a
whole is really nothing more than just a
hope construct that some people latch
onto for the idea of finding a better
tomorrow or making sense out of the
world in which they live but norman
mckay cannot provide this congregation
with the hope that they're looking for
all these individuals who have grown up
in a time before all these new
superheroes rose up and just started
going crazy they remember what the world
was like and they're looking to norman
mckay to help guide them back to
remembering what that world was and that
this won't all be this way but norman
mckay has a hard time being hopeful and
in fact he tells him i can't do this i'm
sorry i can't lie to you i can't fill
you with hope when i don't even have
hope myself and so his congregation of
course basically ends up leaving they
don't so much abandon him but they do
feel a bit of trepidation and
trepidation and shame as they look at
him and they see a man who has seemingly
lost the faith so how could a man with
no faith possibly lead people who are in
need of faith and that's when a
significantly important thing happens in
the life of norman mckay when he's
visited by the spectre now this is
probably the part that you're waiting
for for a lot of you guys out there who
had never read kingdom come yes the
beginning of the story seems to have
nothing to do with dc or any of the
heroes we know it takes a little bit to
kind of get to that point but it all
begins to make sense and so when the
spectre shows up here and basically
tells norman mckay i need your aid here
this vector basically ends up revealing
to norman mckay what his purpose is not
fully but basically giving him an idea
and simply saying i have been sent here
by a higher power in order to judge the
world now here's the thing about this
right that when it comes to the spectre
back when he initially came into
existence he operated independently one
of the things that dc did in order to
both make the spectre more grounded as
well as potentially give him a weakness
as well as have him essentially
have a greater involvement in the dc
landscape was basically bond him to
people and that by bonding the specter
to individuals it was a way to almost
turn the specter from this ethereal you
know godly imbued being to what was
basically a superhero it was kind of
like that in the beginning but the the
way the specter initially appeared back
in the old school all american comics
basically began to move away and it
began to shift so by the time you got to
the events of crisis on infinite earth
he was just this wildly powerful
ethereal force that would just show up
every once in a while and while it was
kind of cool dc was wanting to bring him
back to the world of being a superhero
and so that's one of the ways in which
they did that plus it was cool to have a
person who was basically the embodiment
of god's wrath walking around the world
and so what ends up happening is the
specter basically tells norman mckay you
have been imbued with a portion of the
power that wesley dodds had but more so
than that you are going to be my eyes
and ears here on earth and where norman
mckay is just kind of like why in the
world like what what how could i
possibly be suited to fit this and even
himself doesn't fully seem to comprehend
everything that's going on one of the
things he says is explain this to me
right if you are truly a being of great
power how is it that you can find no way
to avert this catastrophe that you say
is coming this armageddon that you say
is going to take place and the response
to the specter is that is not my task
once earth boasted other saviors who
might have stemmed the tide of
destruction but as you will see they are
no longer the solution they are in many
ways the problem and so what the spectre
does is he brings norman mckay on a
journey to show him all these different
individuals who are the superheroes of
yesterday what happened to batman what
happened to superman what happened to
wonder woman green lantern the flash
those guys and so what we find out here
is he's taken to superman basically on a
farm and that as superman goes around
here of course wesley dodds whispers and
whatnot the response of the spectre is
no no no you're good they yeah he can't
hear you right he can't see or hear you
i have shielded you from this uh i am
that powerful right that not even the
man of steel who can hear virtually
anything can hear you here superman is
effectively met by the arrival of wonder
woman and the cool thing is that wonder
woman the way she speaks here is she
simply says or at least uh you know
communicates that she's been coming here
relatively frequently now one of the
things that i do want to establish here
is that superman does not respond to the
name clark i mean he does but he
responds with disdain right that's not
my name so when wonder woman refers to
him as clark she corrects herself then
refers to him as cow and that's when he
starts talking to her right he was like
you know i haven't seen you in months
what brings you to the farm and this is
what's really interesting here is she
says the vain hope that you're still not
here and superman says these are my
roots right to which he responds you
can't live forever in solitude that what
superman has done here is basically cut
himself off from the rest of humanity
isolated himself in his entirety from
everybody else and what he says is
things can grow here right this place
that i'm in life can really grow and
flourish here and that's when wonder
woman responds but it's all a farce and
when she touches the wall and basically
reveals he's in the fortress of solitude
that he's not actually out there in the
world living it really is superman
living a lie right you know she's she
literally chimes in and she says listen
to me like you have to do something
right like i've come with news from the
outside and it's bad news that news has
that has an effect shaking the world
that he's out of control and that's when
superman says i tried to tell them that
10 years ago i tried to tell them they
backed the wrong horse that they should
not have gone along with that guy but
they did and of course as a result of
that by removing himself from humanity
what superman's doing is effectively
saying i could save you but i'm not
going to you chose this path now you
have to live with it and humanity's been
regretting it every single day and in
fact wonder woman picks up on that and
she says and they don't listen i know
stop punishing them and the response to
superman is i don't care right they
deserve whatever fate they got they
brought it on themselves i feel nothing
for them i have no desire to help them
at all and she says okay fine if that's
true right if if that's really the case
then come with me and let me show you
the world as it exists right now let me
show you the outside world because
you've been hiding from it you've been
ignoring it you've been pretending like
it doesn't exist you cut yourself off
from it just go and watch and see what's
become of the world but steal yourself
right be prepared for what it is that
happens and so he ultimately walks into
his area with the viewing screens and he
simply just says on and that's what we
end up finding out there's just a
colossal event that's taking place that
what had happened is the the villain
parasite had basically been chased down
by the by magog as well as his at least
was referred to as the justice battalion
now magog of course was the character
that you saw in uh infinite frontier and
we'll talk more about him as the story
unfolds because he turns out to be
hugely important but it was a massive
fight between parasite and all these
different guys and parasite was
literally just trying to flee but it was
one of these things where he was begging
for his life he was begging for begging
to be saved he tried to surrender they
wouldn't let him surrender they quite
literally just wanted to kill him and so
in an act of desperation what parasite
had done is he had torn captain adam in
half or at least split him and when that
happened it basically set off a massive
explosion and what we're told is that
early reports indicate immediate
casualties numbering close to a million
as the dying atoms radioactive energy
swept hundreds of kilometers rendering
the entire state of kansas as well as
part of nebraska iowa and missouri in a
radiated wasteland though magog's
comrades have since prevented further
spread of the nuclear blight the total
loss of america's breadbasket this
sterilization of its agrarian culture
has thrown the world economy into near
collapse in the face of global famine
that's what we're looking at here quite
literally the entirety of the american
agricultural industry has just been
annihilated by the force of magog and
the recklessness that came with just
attacking the attacking parasite in that
way and so the response to superman even
after having seen all that is there's
nothing i can do from here go back to
your island diana you're safe there and
walks away right and literally just kind
of like that's it there's nothing i can
do and so you know in that instance the
response of wonder woman is we won't all
sit here and wait like we won't all deal
with this right we're not all going to
sit here and rest on our laurels and
that's when norman mckay asked the
spectre neither will the rest of us who
is she talking about and the spectre
takes him on a tour of a few others and
says that the the idea of superman
abandoning his role as a superhero had a
huge effect on the entire superhero
landscape that some some heroes out
there were so disheartened because they
took their lead from superman they were
so disheartened by seeing him so
demoralized that when he quit they quit
that there were others out there who
basically started functioning in a way
to where they keep their city safe but
nobody ever sees them a really good
example of this is the flash right the
flash just races around the entirety of
keystone city keeping it safe keeping it
protected but nobody ever sees it nobody
ever knows he's there that you have
hawkman who basically operates out in
the pacific northwest as kind of an
environmental protector that you have uh
the green lantern who quite literally
made an emerald citadel for himself that
orbits the earth he's the s the only
occupant there and he spends all of his
days watching for an extraterrestrial
threat that will seemingly never come
that all these different people out
there all these members of the superhero
community in their own ways effectively
did the exact same thing superman did to
a degree now of course you end up having
norma mckay who says but what happened
to batman what happened to gotham city
and what it looks like here is that in
the city of gotham one batman's got an
entirely automated system that runs and
two no crime is tolerated in any
capacity whatsoever none right batman
has actually become far more extreme
than he was when superman existed
because superman represented hope and
even if batman didn't necessarily put
that perception on it permeated him
right the hope he experienced with
superman was the hope that gotham city
could truly become a better place and
the only thing we get here is the
specter telling norman mckay batman has
a city under control and so what happens
is you have norman mckay who is taken to
a bridge and this is probably one of the
single greatest moments in the entirety
of kingdom come he asked them the
question like that's all that's what you
wanted to show me and the specter asked
does that disturb you and the response
of of norman is yes right you're an
angel that makes you a messenger of hope
a greater power sent you your very
existence is a testament to faith you
mean that all you have to tell me is
that those who could save us simply
won't and that's the thing that norma
mckay can't quite grasp his head around
is they could save us it's not like they
were killed they didn't die in action
they just won't they simply just won't
save us and i don't understand why why
are we as humanity simply not worth
saving and so that's when norman mckay
has to come to grips with the fact
humanity did it to itself and so in this
moment when you're on this bridge you
end up having all these these you know
heroes like a great big fight breaks out
here pandemonium starts reigning supreme
you got the heroes against villains if
you could call them that and as usual
people are caught in the crossfire it's
just absolute pandemonium and in fact
what has happened is that in the
aftermath of kansas that because of the
lengths that magog and his forces went
to in order to take out a parasite that
now it kind of feels like all bets are
off right that whenever it comes to this
bar of recklessness and lack of concern
for collateral damage every time he gets
raised by magog everybody else follows
suit so in a lot of ways he's kind of
the opposite of superman right his
antithesis and so it's really kind of
crazy how this how this goes on and so
what you end up getting is in the midst
of all this right you literally have
people who were stuck in a cable car
about to fall to their death right it's
virtually the end of these guys and you
have this thing where it's like can
anybody get out here right nor mckay the
whole time is like don't you understand
right talking to the specter if any of
us are to survive any of us now more
than ever
we need hope and then he says and
suddenly there was a wind right not a
not really a wind a blur of motion
bending the steel of their weapons and
changing the very course of the mighty
river below he says even before the
bystanders freed themselves from the
cable car they knew we all did we knew
and we remembered and somebody says look
somebody else says up in the sky and
it's superman who's finally returned
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section if you guys want me to finish
this i feel like you guys are going to
be like yes
because kingdom come it's just one of
the absolute greatest stories
ever in the history of dc comics right
it's so cool because you get this little
moment here right this little this
little kind of uh kind of a small moment
when when norah mckay basically says
superman had not turned his back on us
right he stands in the sky faith
rewarded he has returned and dear god
the threat of armageddon hasn't ended
it's simply just begun with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later peace